they took everything from me then they  believe this whole so i could sit my  freedom a lot  even a pride  it was hard to know which one I miss the  most sometimes when I'm locked up I  swear the man the plane come back  together  none of it was real or just my head  going to mush but then one day I had a  visitor and that's when everything  changed he said his name was clip so ran  some kind of weird contest and he was  looking for people like me to be a part  of it he told me if i won I could have  the one thing my heart desired I may be  no rocket scientist but I know  opportunity when I see it that pilot had  taken a piece of my life and twisted it  all around how could I refuse the chance  for revenge  today's based on